lei non sarà mai mia madre invece devi
trattarla come se fosse la tua vera
madre e non osare contraddirmi hai
capito bambina dovrai obbedire a tutto
ciò che ti chiedo tuo padre è
morto il principe è
[Musica]
mio
Tesoro sei
qua Sei qua è nata è una femminuccia mia
figlia tesoro piccolina
n Tesoro che succede stai male prenditi
cura di lei
No no tesoro
[Musica]
no
figlia mia ah come Cresci in fretta io
esco e mi raccomando tu studia e fai da
brava certo papà Ci vediamo
dopo devo prendere un po' di legna
dovremo scaldarci Stanotte sarà una
notte
fredda
[Musica]
l'aiuto io Grazie
gentilissima Grazie questo è suo Eh sì E
grazie per avermi aiutato Ecco si figuri
e di queste parti lei sì Ah e vuole fare
un giro con me facciamo una passeggiata
qua volentieri grazie Allora prego
ginocchiata sul pavimento vi cercò a
lungo con la candela tracce di strani
piedi Ah quanto è bello questo libro
figlia lei sarà la tua nuova madre mi
raccomando portale rispetto e
obbedisca mai mia
madre invece devi trattarla come se
fosse la tua vera madre e non osare
contraddirmi
hai capito bambina dovrai obbedire a
tutto ciò che ti
chiedo sono sicuro che vi troverete
molto bene insieme Sì Ness Sono sicura
anch'io Ora noi andiamo Tu continua a
studiare Mi raccomando è una brava
bambina molto studiosa
andiamo
c'è ancora cenere In questo cammino
vieni immediatamente qui a
pulire ti chiamerò
[Musica]
Cenerentola non voglio vedere neanche un
briciolo di
[Musica]
polvere Tesoro cosa stai facendo Che ti
ha detto di pulire il camino sono stata
io deve aiutare nelle faccende di casa
non decidi tu cosa deve fare mia figlia
Io devo decidere e mia figlia deve
studiare tesoro va pure in camera tua
vai a studiare Grazie papà e tu non
permetterti più di dire a mia figlia
quello che deve
[Musica]
fare
Cenerentola devo darti una spiacevole
notizia tuo padre è
morto ma tranquilla da oggi saremo
soltanto noi due insieme alle tue
[Musica]
sorellastre perché non è
possibile
Perché Perché capitano sempre tutti a me
Oh povera
Cenerentola adesso non ci sarà più
nessuno a
difenderti Lasciatemi in pace ho perso
la mia mamma e mio papà non avrai mai
pace finché stai in questa casa e ora
vai a pulire il
camino
Cenerentola pulisci meglio altrimenti la
matrigna ti lascerà senza cena stasera
Sì sì vedi sto
pulendo Sì sì ma non perdere troppo
tempo insomma ci sono tutti i nostri
vestiti da lavare e stirare e noi
ovviamente non li laviamo tieni
impegnati Mi raccomando devono
risplendere
E mi raccomando devono essere puliti e
splendenti buon
lavoro spero che un giorno andrò via per
sempre da questa casa e che sarò
libera
Cen lettola Hai lavato e sistemato il
mio vestito e il mio se non l'hai fatto
stasera niente cena sì sì e quelli qua e
non stropicciarli Ma dove dovete andare
razza di insolente come ti permetti a
chiederci una cosa del genere sono fatti
nostri no Diglielo così morirò
dall'invidia va bene Siamo state
invitate al ballo del re il principe sta
cercando una moglie e sicuramente
sceglierà me sceglierà me no me me me me
Ma posso venire
anch'io Assolutamente no una come te non
potrebbe mai venire al ballo di un
principe Cenerentola pulisci che è
l'unica cosa che sai fare Pulisci
pulisci
Cenerentola il ballo poteva essere la
mia occasione per scappare via da questa
casa ma sono vestita di stracci e anche
sporca di cenere Non mi farà non mai
entrare al ballo di un principe vestita
così e quindi non ci posso
[Musica]
andare Ci penso io con un incantesimo
farà apparire un bellissimo abito per il
ballo e anche una carrozza Ma attenzione
a mezzanotte l'incantesimo svanirà Ok
Bid bobidi
Bo Wow È
bellissimo Grazie fatamadrina Sei
stupenda però vai vai subito al ballo
adesso sì vado
Grazie ciao sono l'emoji di Anita vuoi
sapere tu a quale principessa
corrispondi Clicca subito mi piace sotto
a questo video e l'ultima cifra che ti
capiterà nel mi piace corrisponde a una
delle principesse che vedi scritte qua a
fianco quale ti è capitata e ora
torniamo subito al
video il castello Chissà dov'è il
principe sarà mio Andiamo a cercarlo ma
non si trova Ma dov'è finito vabbè
intanto
[Musica]
balliamo che un principe
verita è mio è mio è mio è mio è mio è
[Musica]
mio
principe
[Musica]
Quella quella è
Cenerentola Sì l'ho vista come ha fatto
ad avere quel vestito dobbiamo
sbarazzarci ci ha rovinato l'unica
occasione di parare con il principe Ho
un'idea io vai Pensaci
[Musica]
tu il principe È mio No no Ma cosa hai
fatto c l' rentola c l'
rentola no ce l' rentola non mi lasciare
ce l'è ventola No ora che ti ho trovata
come faccio vivere senza di
[Musica]
te era solo un sogno Eppure mi sembrava
tutto così
[Musica]
reale
Bid